يبدأ توني بلينكن تصريحاته،
فلنستمع للشهادة أمامكم
اليوم، المناطق المأهولة بالسكان توقف عن دعم
الإبادة الجماعية
وكل سكان غزة، أطلقوا النار الآن،
أنقذوا أطفال غزة، أنقذوا
أطفال غزة، حريق البحر الآن، أين
فخركم يا أمريكا،
أفعل ذلك  أدرك أن الناس يشعرون
بحماس شديد ولكني أطلب أن يكون لدينا
نظام في غرفة الاستماع هذه، لقد
استثمرنا في تحديث
جيشنا واستثمرنا في
أعظم أصولنا الإستراتيجية في الخارج،
وشبكة حلفائنا وشركائنا التي
تنمو بشكل أكبر وأقوى.  نحن متحدون
وأكثر قدرة من أي وقت مضى، نحن ندافع عن
مصالحنا وقيمنا ولا
نتراجع، لا في مواجهة
العدوان الروسي على أوكرانيا، ولا في
مواجهة المنافسة الاستراتيجية الشديدة
في منطقة المحيط الهادئ الهندية وفي
جميع أنحاء العالم، مذبحة شجاعة 66٪
سيتم تعليق الشاهد وأطلب من
الجميع احترام جلسة الاستماع هذه مرة أخرى،
وسنعلقها حتى
تطالب القاعة بوقف إطلاق النار، عار عليك،
العالم كله يدعو إلى وقف إطلاق النار،
الشعب الأمريكي لا يريد دعم
هذه الحرب الوحشية، أوقفوا  الحرب أوقف
وقف إطلاق النار الآن توقف عن تمويل هذه
المذبحة الوحشية التي ترتكبها إسرائيل بحق
الشعب OFA اضبط النار الآن اضبط النار الآن
اضبط النار الآن شكرًا لك أيها السيناتور وميض
إذا
كنت كما قلت فإننا ندافع عن
القيم ولا تتقلص مرة أخرى ليس في  في
مواجهة العدوان الروسي على
أوكرانيا ليس في مواجهة
المنافسة الاستراتيجية المتزايدة في منطقة
المحيط الهادئ الهندية وفي جميع أنحاء العالم وليس في
مواجهة الإرهاب والدول الراعية له